[Applause]
are the European Union it's sort of like
the windows of politics did slow it
doesn't work perfectly and sometimes it
just crashes nonetheless all that has to
be honest the other alternatives are not
much better and can certainly be more
costly at the beginning of this year it
seems like the far right was unstoppable
some political analysts claimed that
brexit would be the beginning of the end
for the European Union and during this
time the international media was full of
words like freshness or checks it
however this euro skeptic Fuhrer wasn't
to last for long Frances elected a brand
new president in Manuel Makram who
stands up for the European Union like no
one else the same has happens in other
elections around Europe in other words
the European Union is alive and kicking
at least for the next four years
but do hold on for just a minute because
things are more complex than what they
might seem in fact not all EU fans are
the same and many of them don't even
share the same opinion on what the EU
should be for instance the chrome stands
for a fiscal union with the same taxes
in every country certainly the Angela
Merkel nor John Claude Juncker are into
that on the other hand the former
Belgian Prime Minister give the hofstadt
who is now president of the European
Liberal Party says that Europe should
become a federation like the United
States but does everyone agree with that
well the answer is rather unsurprisingly
no in fact the only thing shared by all
these politicians is the fact that the
EU is a good thing
so now the questions are well what is
the European Union we'll about what
should it become is it a Federation or a
confederation and what are the different
models on the negotiation table
well today we are going to answer all of
these questions what did Margaret
Thatcher was right Margaret Thatcher is
something like Elvis Presley to
Euroskeptics for decades that this woman
who is the British prime minister in the
1980s has become the biggest inspiration
for many of the movements that want to
end the European project but then again
reality is seldom simple now it is true
that Margaret Thatcher was a big critic
of political integration back in the
time the European Union still didn't
exist it was just a community of
countries that traded among themselves
nevertheless during the 1980s different
European governments agreed to deepen
this integration this is when they
started talking about a single currency
and new institution all of this
culminated in 1992 with the signing of
the Maastricht Treaty so the question is
what did Margaret Thatcher think about
all of this well the truth is different
forget about stereotypes and we actually
read her memoir we find prints like this
[Music]
riki does not dream of some cozy
isolated existence on the fringes of the
european community our destiny is in
Europe as part of the community but
importantly this doesn't mean that
thatcher was in total agreements with
all the european politicians she just
wanted a different model unlike those
who wanted a United States of Europe
with the capital in Brussels she stood
for a Confederate model certainly we
want to see Europe more United and was a
greater sense of common purpose but it
must be in a way which preserves the
different traditions parliamentary
powers and sense of national pride in
one's own country
poor we keep going we got to explain
what's the difference between a
federation and a confederation an
example of a federation would be the
United States of America Texas in
California have their own legislatures
their own governments and their own laws
today for instance marijuana is legal in
California but illegal in Texas however
if the Congress in Washington DC were to
pass a law legalizing cannabis across
the country any state law that would
contradict the federal one would be
automatically abolished in a
confederation that states have way more
autonomy today there are actually no
Confederations in the world not even in
Switzerland of course then Switzerland
the different Canton's enjoy a lot of
autonomy and different taxes but that
doesn't mean they are a confederation
for instance if the Parliament of Brno
would pass the law legalizing marijuana
the rest of the Canton's would have to
accept it
if Switzerland was a real Confederation
each of the different assemblies would
have to have a vote to decide whether
they want to keep cannabis legal or not
so despite what a lot of people say
Switzerland is clearly a federation and
so now you might be wondering well what
exactly is Europe then is it a
Federation or a confederation of course
there are a lot of people who stand for
the federal model in the last few years
the champion of this idea has been the
presidents of the Liberals either
hofstadt that we need to reform Europe
to make it a real Federation capable to
act not only on in the economic fields
but also by establishing a defense union
by establishing a European investigation
capacity but let's go down to the facts
today despite what it looks like
national governments have a lot of
autonomy for instance years ago Brussels
passed the directive banning smoking in
bars after that each of the member
countries had to vote on their own and
Peter backer law men as well you know
what happened well Austria and the Czech
Republic did not pass those laws and
during those years you could smoke in
the cafe's of Prague or Vienna while in
Berlin and Paris it was completely
forbidden
feelings of the 80 which is the main
European taxes difference in each
country in say maybe twenty one percent
but in Hungary they pay twenty seven
percent ends in Germany they've got a
nineteen percent tax in other words your
if is not a Federation's that it's also
not a confederation either it's kind of
a Federal Confederation and now you're
probably wondering is this Federal
Confederation model actually working or
do we need to move ahead with some sort
of the United States of Europe what's
wrong in the European Union we all heard
about the many mistakes this European
integration has made that the traces
many of these flaws could have happened
in the Member States individually as an
example let us have a look at the
refugee crisis now it is true that
Brussels was incapable of crafting a
common policy to give asylum to all the
citizens that are running away from
countries like Syria Iraq or Libya but
let's not lie to ourselves the same
happens in every single country in Spain
for example the national government did
everything they could to avoid welcoming
the refugees on the other hand Madrid
City Hall did the exact opposite
devaluation an absolute project earlier
Casillas City Hall of Madrid will make a
welcoming project so the refugees will
have a place to live in other words we
cannot expect Brussels to solve the
problems that nation-states have always
had in politics of things they're simply
not possible
but do you hold on for a moment because
this does not mean the European Union is
perfect either in fact there are many
problems that are endemic to this
institution
[Music]
for example let's imagine you are a
freelancer living in Hungary and you
work for a company based in Belgium
should you include dat on the invoice
that you said to them well according to
EU legislation you shouldn't because
well it's a service contract that each
country has its own tax laws that in
many cases contradicts the EU laws but
not only that what dat should you
include on that invoice the Hungarian
one or the Belgium one all these
problems could be solved if there was a
common ground on taxation matters but
many countries don't want to lose
sovereignty on this matter
and no one dares make the first step
towards them
you
so as you might imagine from this it's
pretty hard for important decisions to
move forward so the question is what
could be the solution to this problem a
club with different kinds of members
constitutions they are useful they allow
politicians and legislators to know what
they can do and what they can't it's
sort of like a minimal agreement this
way a government knows what it can pass
as a law and it's a system that has been
proven effective so well what's the
problem well all the attempts to release
a European Constitution have failed in
2005 both France and the Netherlands had
referendums where they rejected the
proposal for a European Magna Carta
years later Brussels politicians met
again to write a new version of this
Constitution these so-called Lisbon
Treaty this was a milder version of the
previously drafted constitution but
integration problems persisted the truth
is that each country has its own
interests and it's hard to get them all
on the same page so why not just
recognize the differences and this is
why the European Commission has made the
European white book where they imagine
five potential scenarios for a new
reform one of them would allow each
state to have a different level of
integration on the other hand at the
beginning of 2017 the economists
proposed to create a European Union with
different kinds of memberships at one
hand there would be a premium member who
would share a common currency
common fiscal policy and a common
foreign policy or another one there
would be a silver member who would just
share a common market and the free
movement area other members let's call
them the bronze category would have
access to just the common market
this way it would be way easier to
convince every country to pass a
European Constitution in the meantime
the idea of a United States of Europe
it's lost a lot of supporters the idea
of a Europe with different membership
levels however currently enjoys a lot of
support meanwhile Frances brand-new
president is willing to play a major
role in the future of Europe but what
does he really stand for well we're not
answering that in this video but if
you'd like to know more about Emmanuel
macron don't forget to check out this
video that we take so now our question
to you is do you think this hybrid of a
federal Confederation with different
than the categories can actually work or
should we keep trying for a federation
where everyone has the same rules please
do let us know what you think in the
comment section below and by the way
we'd like to thank professor Oscar
Sanchez a constitutional expert from the
University of Valladolid for helping us
in making this video and if you're new
to visual politics please do not forget
to subscribe we publish brand new videos
every Monday and Thursday so do hit that
subscribe button below so you won't miss
any post and if you like this video do
give it a thumbs up and as always I'll
see you next time and if you'd like to
hear more of my lovely voice you can
join us at reconsider the podcast that
covers politics but we don't do the
thinking for you available on your
favorite podcast see you there
[Music]
you